- I started to feel like,
maybe they're transphobic.
- Or maybe they're closeted trans.
- You know what, I feel
like that's a thing.
- It is a thing, it is totally a thing.
(mellow music)
Hi, my name is Christina.
- Hi, I'm Skylar, and my
preferred pronouns are he and him.
- And my pronouns are she and her.
(mellow music)
- I was like mom, I know you
think I'm gay, but I'm not.
She didn't like, fully understand.
And then she did her own research on it.
She became more accepting of it.
It was better for me because
it made my life easier and
happier as a person to know
that my mom was okay with it,
cause my mom means like everything to me.
- I was physically and verbally assaulted,
I just had people like
scream awful things at me
while I was walking through the hallway.
But I think, once I was in seventh grade,
it honestly wasn't as
bad, it's just, you know,
sixth grade is such a hard
year anyway for everyone,
and especially when you're
trans and you're trying
to deal with all of these
things and trying to just deal
with junior high school in
general, it it so stressful.
(upbeat music)
A big part of me is being trans, and like,
if that means that that person
isn't going to be friends
with me then so be it, because honestly,
I'd rather that people know that I'm trans
and not be friends with me,
than someone not know that I'm
trans and be friends with me
for so long and not know
this huge part of my identity
that I'm so proud of.
- After I transitioned, my
friends were so supportive of me.
Yeah, they don't bring
up that I am transgender,
they don't bring it up at
all, because it's like,
what is there to bring up?
(upbeat music)
Yeah, so I didn't wanna
go to the girls restroom,
and then I couldn't go
to the boys restroom,
because everyone just looked at me.
I would actually like,
take my time and walk
across the campus to go
use the port-a-potties.
The fact that I actually
wanted to go to a port-a-potty
instead of a bathroom that was marked--
- That's really sad.
- It's sad because they're not clean.
- It's just so awful that
like, trans people are made out
to almost be like, if we're
predators or something,
like going into the bathroom
to do something to someone,
you know, I feel like people
should just able to use
whatever bathroom they wanna use, I mean,
it's a bathroom, you know?
(upbeat music)
- A teacher that I really
remember in my high school,
her name is Miss Marquez.
When all my classmates were
calling me by my other name,
the one that I wanted, she
kinda took note of that,
and she pulled me aside
one day, and she's like,
so, you want me to call you Skylar?
And I'm like, yes, please.
And then she's like, do you want me to
call you by male pronouns?
And I was like well, yes,
I would appreciate that.
Out of all the teachers I
had, she really made me feel
okay about myself.
- You know, I've dealed
with awful counselors
that weren't accepting, but, I mean,
I've also had really good experiences.
My third grade teacher,
before I transitioned,
has never messed my pronouns up,
has never messed my name up,
I just wish that there were
more teachers like him,
because honestly, I've just
not had the best teachers.
(mellow music)
If you're a trans person out there that is
watching this video right now,
I just want you know
that it's gonna be hard,
but it's so worth it in
the end when you are able
to be yourself and be able to
feel comfortable in your skin.
(mellow music)
We've been in your bathroom forever.
- We've been there.
I've seen the men's restroom,
it's not that clean.
Girls restrooms are cleaner.
(laughter)
It's just true.
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)